hey guys Pete here alright this is gonna
be my third mr. robot video this week
this is my things you might have missed
video for season three episode two you
know look at little Easter eggs
callbacks details you might have missed
some of them are fairly obvious and you
might have seen them but it's still fun
to discuss the episode once again
because there's just so much stuff
layered inside of it let's jump into
these ones and you guys can tell me in
the comments if you caught this stuff or
not there was a lot of talk about home
alone in this episode Eliot mentioned
that him and Darlene were obsessed but I
saw a thread on reddit from the redditor
INF MCD who pointed out that the first
time we saw a nod to home alone was
actually in season 1 episode 7 in that
episode
Shayla told Elliot to keep the fish you
filthy animal talking about QWERTY I an
FM CD pointed out that that came from a
movie inside of a movie where McKay you
know Kevin McCallister who was played by
Macaulay Culkin the main character used
a clip that said keep the change you
filthy animal so he used that clip to
get a free pizza and to me it's pretty
compelling that the reason that Shane
Lee used that was referring to that part
of the film I mean it's definitely a
popular movie so so that's something to
think about next thing you might have
missed was the person wearing the F
Society mask in the new video that came
out appears to have a beard
unfortunately that doesn't really clear
things up on who it is we know that
there's a bearded tyrell in the next
episode from the next trailer but based
on what the video says that doesn't seem
to line up with the right timeline
Mowgli has a beard but he's not yet been
credited on season 3 as far as I've seen
and we haven't seen any looks at him
from any of the trailer footage so what
does the beard actually mean well I
don't know I mean it's up for
speculation but it's definitely clear
there mr. robot is the obvious choice
since he wears a cropped beard it looks
a little bit darker
and longer in the picture but we can't
really say for sure the this really
heavily distorted the VHS footage so
your guess is as good as mine
the next thing you might have missed was
brought up by redditor red wheelbarrow
barbecue or red wheelbarrow BB Q he
posted an image that shows that Elias
address is confusing this is something I
probably never would have caught but red
wheelbarrow BB Q pointed it out and lots
of people seem to have noticed it in the
photo you can see that on his bottle of
meds and on the fbi's board it has a
different address than what's actually
on the building and in this reddit
thread there was discussion about how
the addresses are made up and well
wouldn't that just be 207 next door but
I mean it says 217 on the doorway where
Elliott enters so what does it mean it
could be nothing
it could be continuity errors there
Bible on where Elliott lives might be
mistaken and so then when they do the
props they use the wrong address or it
could be something huge you know what I
mean the reddit post kind of brings this
up in the context of the Mandela effect
and I'm not ready to go down that road
yet but there's a lot of people pitching
different kinds of parallel universe
alternate universe alternate timeline
kind of series the next thing you might
have missed was that the subreddit I
mentioned in last week's video actually
showed up on Elliott's screen in this
video the inside eat Corp subreddit that
I talked about it just flashes for a
second but it's worth noting because it
adds some context to the Easter Egg and
all the other reddit stuff that's there
plus if this one shows up does that mean
that the others will still play a part
in season 3 I mean I don't really know
about that because they're all
interconnected so this may be the only
important one but I mean there's quite a
few different posts they're on four
different sub reddits that I've looked
at and there may be other stuff I mean
there is other stuff it links to but
there may be other sub reddits as well I
don't know so that's really kind of cool
and I didn't
added to this list because it wasn't
current but there is one of that's
really interesting to me which I might
bring up in more detail in a different
video the next thing you might have
missed was red Adair king of the wild
front
pointed out that there's a book on
Elliot's shelf and it looks like it is
the report by Jessica Francis Kane the
red Adair went and looked up the
synopsis of the book and it kind of jive
z-- a little bit with the Washington
Township scenario it's about the war
time in Europe but last section of it
says there's only decades later when the
case is reopened by one of the children
who survived that the facts can finally
be brought to light so that's pretty
cool does it mean anything I mean I feel
like they put stuff in places for a
reason when they do sets but the reason
here is probably because if you went and
looked up what this book was about then
it would give you that little bit of
connection I don't think it explains
anything beyond that all throughout mr.
robot when Eliot's on the train we've
seen several different cool things in
the advertisements in other words they
dress the advertisements with their own
stuff redditor bkn Apple pointed out
that one of the ads behind Elliott in
the emoji scene is for a company called
Flair FA ll er II now that's the verb
version of fallow and fallow means to
lie deceive so the idea that BK and
Apple had was is that this is a clear
sign that Elliot's lying to us again now
that's a whole rabbit hole that we could
go down in a different context besides
this video I think it's interesting I
can't think of a single instance where
there was a real ad in any of those
shots so they make these things up for a
reason and I mean Elliott is the
unreliable narrator so saying he's lying
to us again isn't really a big surprise
now you could take this to be that he is
purposely withholding information to us
like he did about being in jail but
again I'm not ready to go down that road
this point in the same emoji sequences
another redditor underscore j-- Adler
jad Ellie are pointed out that there's a
man and a woman on the train behind him
they don't have the emoji heads
obviously that look a lot like the man
and woman that took Angela to the White
Rose meeting the female especially
there's a pretty compelling case the
redditor he wrote it out a little bit
more and showed some different photos of
the actor who plays the man in this
couple here because in the truck it
doesn't really look the same to me but
it's bad lighting and you know whatever
you can't say for sure but it does
appear that this couple would be the
same or even if they're not they could
be important in the same way one of the
things that stood out to me as
interesting and I mentioned it in my
episode to recap was that Eliot's
thought that he gave the story of being
pushed out the window to Krista at an
earlier time it turns out that he
actually did in his own mind at least
going off the book the red wheelbarrow
that they put out in between redditor
David Schwimmer
that is his handle posted a screenshot
of the book where it said you know he
talks about it directly telling her
about being pushed out the window with
that in mind it's another one of those
things I mean what Elliot does and what
Elliot believes and what Elliot tells us
are three separate things so Elliot
lying to himself Elliot lying to us
Elliot lying to Krista those are all
things that happen and he believes it
obviously when he wrote it down there's
no reason for him to write that down in
his book but I feel like that goes to
his unreliability more than it has
anything to do with Krista Krista to me
and Mike watching was being sincere not
knowing about it that's really all it
feels like to me but it could be a hint
to something more so we'll have to keep
an eye on it the next thing you might
have missed is something that maybe if
you haven't watched or rewatched season
one recently you might have forgotten
about but when Elliot's crying in this
last episode it's almost exactly the
same shot that we saw in season one
where he's leaning against the
all I think that's interesting and it
ties into the next thing and that was
the separation anxiety poster that we
saw behind him in the subway scene now
that's an interesting poster on a lot of
levels there's a person holding a head
like a body holding their own head looks
like a severed head there and the head
kind of resembles Elliott plus the
actors are pretty funny when you think
about it but you know this is in the
context of him being asked about missing
mr. robot and remember when he was
crying in season one that was directly
related to being alone after he sort of
pushed F Society and mr. robot away so
even though Elliott spends most of his
time trying to get rid of mr. robot
there is a part of him that is attached
to the idea of always having someone
around so I thought that was pretty
interesting and the crying you know is I
think it's a pretty specific callback
they could have had him crying doing
anything but they chose to do it in the
scene that looked like and was framed
like the one in season one now the Arg
is fully underway at this point there's
just tons of stuff that those guys are
finding and decoding over there I'm not
quite code oriented or codebreaker
oriented enough to really take part in
that I do like to watch and check their
threads whenever to see what they find
and what they do with it
and there's actually a page I'll put a
link to it in the description that keeps
track of all these because there's
really too many of them at this point
for me to bring them up and every one of
these videos you know there's several
things that go to happen on the website
there's Ecore like the who is mr. robot
site and then there's the equine site so
if you sign up for both of those you'll
get emails and you get on those sites
and you can find different things I
noticed that there you know they had a
connection on the computer that was like
Elliott's desktop and there were some
simple things there like you could make
it was like HR stuff you know you can
make your nameplate for your cubicle and
so on and so forth but obviously there
was more to that and the people on the
subreddit for the Arg were digging
through that the equine website did give
away another
this week they gave away in Amazon Alexa
dot again I didn't get there in time
they were all gone by the time I click
through but that's really cool that they
do that that if you follow their emails
that you could possibly get one of these
things in the mail the coin banks that I
mentioned last week actually did start
to arrive I saw people that were lucky
enough to get one of those are starting
to see them coming in the mail and like
I said on the Arg we see tons of stuff
interesting things going on with things
that were on the screen different URLs
and stuff like that and I'll keep an eye
on if there's something really really
related to the show itself not just the
Arg I'll bring it up in the next video
so that's about it for this week I'm
getting pretty excited for this Tyrell
flashback episode that's coming up make
sure you check out my episode to recap
if you haven't seen it and make sure you
check out my episode 3 trailer breakdown
speaking of Tyrell flashbacks a lot of
cool stuff in that little trailer there
please like the video if you enjoyed it
please subscribe to my channel and turn
on notifications so you'll know when my
new mr. robot videos come out I've
fallen into a schedule of three videos a
week right now and will probably do some
bonus videos as they come up make sure
you follow me on my Twitter account and
Instagram and Facebook if you like to
use those you can get in touch with me
pretty easily over there thanks for
watching guys I will talk to you soon